grenoble en france une agglomération de
450 mille habitants niché au pied des
alpes
sa superficie est identique à celle de
québec
mais les deux villes se distinguent par
leur choix en matière de mobilité
il y a une trentaine d'années avec un
mince appui populaire de 53%
grenoble s'est dotée d'un tramway
nous avons tenu bon nous avons fait la
fête et puis on a reconnu quelques temps
après quand on l'a fini l'aménagement
d'accès une réussite
michel destot a été maire de grenoble
pendant près de 20 ans ils placent
l'expansion du réseau de tramways parmi
ses plus grandes réalisations depuis
1987 plus de 40 km de rails ont été
posées à chaque jour environ 240 milles
déplacements sont enregistrées dans les
80 stations
le succès du tramway grenoble n'est plus
à démontrer même si le réseau de
transport de l'agglomération propose
plusieurs dizaines de parcours d'autobus
c'est le tramway avec ses cinq lignes
qui génère 65 % des déplacements
mais attention ce succès d'achalandage
n'est pas le fruit du hasard sur les
lignes principales
un tramway circulent en moyenne toutes
les 3 à 5 minutes
le coût d'un passage unique est fixé à 1
euro 60 centimes soit à peine de dollars
40 canadien présentement à québec
il faut prévoir trois de leurs cinq ans
pour monter dans un autobus
la mobilité ces endroits il faut
permettre à chacun quel que soit son
revenu de pouvoir se déplacer iliad
mongaburu en étonnera plusieurs par son
allure décontractée mais c'est lui le
nouveau président du smtc l'équivalent
du réseau de transport de la capitale
chez nous lors des élections municipales
de 2014
ils étaient au nombre des candidats
écologistes qui ont créé la surprise en
prenant le pouvoir à grenoble depuis la
nouvelle administration à limiter la
vitesse à 30 km heure dans 80% des rues
et reconfigurer plusieurs artères en
sens unique pour favoriser les
déplacements à pied ou à vélo
n'empêche il se défend d'avoir déclaré
la guerre à l'auto ce sont des mesures
qui permettent d'améliorer la sécurité
routière et qui permettent de diminuer
les pollutions dans le territoire alors
ici la parc c'est quoi retirer du débat
public
michel destot souligne pour sa part la
façon dont le tramway à transformer
grenoble on a reconquis comme on dit
l'urbanisme de cette ville qui n'était
pas peut-être extrêmement belle quand
vous avez des villes comme lyon ou
bordeaux qui sont les villes très unie
très belle évidemment paris sur l'avenue
jean jaurès lors des travaux de la ligne
e complété en 2015
les voies du tram ont été gazonné et des
traverses pour piétons ajouté la ville a
choisi de retirer deux voies de
circulation dans chaque direction afin
d'aménager des trottoirs élargis mais le
chantier qui a duré deux ans a paralysé
le quartier alors je sais pas comment il
fait le québec n'y suis pas allé encore
j'espère y aller je venais revoir une
fois que les travaux seront finis cette
commerçante préfère en rire mais elle
jure avoir vécu l'enfer et travaux du
tram sont très très dur pour pas se
voiler la face pour tout ce qui est
commerce
c'est traite c'est un passage qui est
très très difficile la disparition de la
moitié des stationnement sur rue à fait
mal au commerce et la circulation est
souvent lourde sur la seule voie
automobile restantes tu l'avais débris
fille sur le deuil et coussins etc mais
selon ce fleuriste l'avenue jean jaurès
se transforme pour le mieux vous voyez
c'est un quartier qui bouge c'est pas un
quartier qui est devenu morts en tout
cas il y avait du monde avant quand
c'était beaucoup de voitures il ya du
monde aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup de
piétons des arrêts de tram etc
malgré les irritants personnes à
grenoble ne semble remettre en question
le tramway le plus récent projet de
prolongement toujours en cours a été
lancée sans la moindre opposition ici
olivier lemieux radio-canada grenoble